an autopsy on gabby potito confirms that
the young woman was strangled petito was
last seen alive in august during a trip
with her fiance investigators have ruled
her death a homicide that fiance bryant
laundry disappeared after he returned
alone to the florida home that they
shared with his parents he's considered
a person of interest and police are
still trying to find him erika duncan
has been following this story since it
began jericho that was very tough news
to hear yesterday good morning to you
the coroner would not divulge many
details citing wyoming state law the
autopsy showed petito's body had been
outside in the wilderness three to four
weeks before it was found in wyoming's
grand teton national park on september
19th the coroner said law enforcement
officials took dna samples from her body
petito and laundry had been traveling
together for two months on a
cross-country trip that they were
documenting on social media weeks before
her disappearance petito told police
that she and laundry got into a physical
altercation petito was reported missing
on september 11 after laundry returned
home to florida in their van without her
and refused to cooperate with
investigators just days later laundry
disappeared his parents told police he
went hiking at a nearby nature preserve
laundry has been charged with
unauthorized use of petito's debit card
after she disappeared in a statement the
laundry family attorney wrote brian is
still missing and when he is located he
will address the pending fraud charge
against him petito's family declined to
comment on the autopsy results
authorities continue to search for
laundry in that 25 thousand acre nature
reserve in florida but to hear the
details it can't be any easier for this
family that's what i that's where my
first thought went to rica listen no
motive and no no uh
cause of death would be acceptable at
this point but to hear it was
strangulation because you know that it
was that's up close and personal she's
probably looking at the person who's
killing her so for the family to see her
so alive and that gold t-shirt that
she's been wearing and the jeans that we
all know and they certainly know yeah
really got to me yesterday when i heard
this news same here and then you've got
the laundry family using the word
missing one yes right so also maddening
tony
is hiding yeah it seems like the more
answers that they get the more questions
they have exactly
to be continued for sure thank you
jerica